all right
it's time to try and get know the war
doctor a little better
[Applause]
[Music]
so something that's been on my to-do
list for a while was to try and get a
better sense of John Hurt's war doctor
he has been skirting in the round the
bottom of my rankings when I have ranked
the doctors of late and the reason for
that has less to do with anything
inherently wrong with them but just
because I felt like I had the least to
go on pretty much any other doctor who
is on the lower end of things I can
justify but in the case of John Hurt's
war doctor I just couldn't give a reason
to put him any higher really all he has
is the one special and you know that one
you know twist at the very end the name
of the doctor but you cannot have the
count that is characterization so as a
result I have been wanting for a long
time to get a better sense of this
doctor and what sort of stories he gets
involved in so that I can assess him
more fairly and I have been very excited
for a while now to finally get around to
Big Finish the war doctor so I've
listened to series one titled only the
monstrous now right off the bat it got
me excited because I have already
listened to the war master only the good
which was great so just the rhyming
nature of the titles the fact that it is
set around the time war how much I loved
the war master how much I liked John
Hurt as an actor how excited I was to
find out more this was a really
disappointing listen I tend to think
that I don't go into these things with
too many specific expectations but I
guess this was the case where I actually
did I just didn't realize what they were
until the thing failed to meet them
the big thing that was incredibly
disappointing for me about this is how
straightforward the story is big finish
in general at least my feelings of my
favorite Big Finish are the ones that do
something either structurally or tonally
that the TV show couldn't get away with
whether that be Doctor Who on
with its wild what-if scenarios whether
that be the the insane sort of
mind-bending types of stories that orbit
Sherman has a tendency to write or
whether that just be really diving into
complete just creepiness with something
like spare parts to a degree that the
show often is reluctant to do or to do
something in this war light fanciful
thing like some of the Fourth Doctor
audio adventures that I've heard that
like there was one that was very much
like a PG woodhouse drama and that that
was sort of a fun thing and something
that the show probably wouldn't try and
do it's when those things happen that I
get the most excited by Big Finish so I
had really hoped that for the war doctor
they would especially something that is
meant to be taking place during the time
war that they'd really pull out all the
stops and I don't feel like they did it
all it feels incredibly frustratingly
safe and I've heard some time war
material before I've heard already and I
have a review up for the first series in
the box set of the Eighth Doctor time
war stories and that one the better
stories in that set were giving you some
nice little glimpses and insight of the
impacts of a time war the way that it is
truly fundamentally completely screwing
up the course of time and the full
extent of that it it felt like that box
that was just skimming the surface this
to what extent is time involved in this
there's a time jump forward Wow there's
a weapon that gets set off at the
beginning it's called like the time
destructor or something which it's just
a bomb for all intents and purposes it's
just a bomb there is a distinct lack of
imagination at playing this boxset and
the other thing is is that for me with
the box sets they are also at the best
one they can be morale
self-contained stories with connective
tissue again I kind of hold up the war
master as the best one that I've
listened to so far but this one is
basically just telling a story in three
parts it's not really done until you get
to the end and Wow one would hope that
would lend it to a sense of greater
sense of grandeur and epicness
it just doesn't because there's nothing
particularly exceptional about this
story the doctor is involved in a
attempt to set off this weapon to take
out the Daleks it cripples them decently
he survives he ends up crash landing on
a planet that is inhabited by a peaceful
race he is crotchety as you would expect
and he tries to help them a little he
leaves he comes back and they have been
completely overrun by a rival race that
has aligned itself with the now
recovering Dalek forces he gets sent
back to this same planet - supposedly
rescue the doctor gets sent back to the
same blood - supposedly rescue a Time
Lord who was captured turns out that
time loads actually negotiating or
trying to negotiate peace with the
Daleks so we've got we've got a whole
appeasement allegory going on but as
exactly as you would expect it doesn't
pan out and it just it's very very very
predictable and I listened to the making
of segments at the end of it and it was
very telling because it you know it
sites very openly you know wanting to
pull World War two story vibe I'm gonna
actually say that it succeeds at that
relatively well but that's to his
detriment
because it makes it much more ordinary
while I appreciate pulling on that as a
source for a general feel and vibe it
does it so well that it makes the time
war in this settings way more
comprehensible than it should be to me
the reason I've always been hesitant to
think that they should even tackle the
time war is that the time war should be
too big too complex too insane to
possibly convey in a narrative even
multiple narratives and the 8th doctor
Tom or Bach said I'd listen to gave me
that kind of time war first of all we
weren't frontline and that we were just
skirting around the edges of it and
still getting this insane stuff going on
here we're supposedly like right up
front and it's just it's just it's just
a war story it's so bog-standard this
whole thing and actually the I have very
mixed feelings about the appeasement
allegory that's going on and the third
part of this because look on the one
hand the if any creation in sci-fi has a
right to involve the the appeasement
allegory
it's the Daleks because the Daleks were
blatantly demonstrable II we know for a
fact created as a parallel to the Nazis
so if you're gonna parallel the Nazis
you're kind of within your rights to
also parallel some of the other stuff
that went around that including the
attempt by the British government before
formal war was declared to appease
genocide 'el maniacs and try and meet
them halfway which doesn't work and I
mean that's all that is a lesson worth
keeping in mind that when you are
dealing with a force that ideologically
incompatible with peace because when
your objective is the extermination of
other life there you don't have a
peaceful middle ground to land at but
when people try and negotiate
with you that is never going to work out
well for them that's a lesson worth
keeping in mind just in life in the
world but at the same time it feels
really obvious and lazy especially the
way it's characterized and especially
the way that the Time Lord character who
is trying to accomplish peace is
depicted which is pigheaded ly committed
to the idea of peace to the point of
unreasonableness and that's where it
loses me that's where it stops being
just an allegory for something that did
happen and starts becoming a straw man
the the degree when when the arguments
and the facts are presented to him the
degree to which he keeps insisting no we
can maybe we can make peace we can maybe
and look you can cite a historical
precedent that there were actually
people still insisting you know even
after the war had started that maybe we
should try and make peace with odds it's
like I know that did happen but for the
purposes of telling a story it makes him
an unreasonable character even if you're
basing him on real life unreasonable
actions so at that point the character
lost all depth and the message lost its
impact because there if there was
anything to be had from that it needed
to ride the line it needed to sell the
at least the possibility that maybe he
had a point and it never really does and
that part of that is the problem of
doing this with the Daleks at all
because we as an audience we know the
Daleks too well we know this isn't gonna
work so it's it's a it's already a dead
end of a narrative to even venture down
because we know there's no there's no
feasible way for this to work I will say
that there was a moment between at the
very end of the second story where the
Daleks are chanting peace in our time
that what I what I thought was going on
was a very clever wordplay but then
and maybe it was but like they never did
anything with it because it's like this
whole thing it's mentioned in the second
one and none of this pays off and the
third one but it's nicer than the second
one of the of these three stories that
the Daleks are kind of stuck the the
idea is to isolate them in their own bit
of time so it becomes their time and so
the idea is peace in our time not the
grand sense of the time in which we live
but like this pocket of time which is
our time peace in our time
I though those quite clever and it was
probably on purpose but but like they
didn't run with that in any meaningful
way and the third one the performances
are also bit mixed
this has Cardinal olestra who was also
in the eighth dr. Big Finish Seth I
listen to I didn't really like her there
either I I understand the functional
role that the character plays in terms
of being the Time Lord who is really
stuck in on the military end of things
and has if she ever had morals they are
so well compromised at this point she
might as they might as well be
completely gone but I just don't find
her compelling I think the main thing is
she yeah a bit like the complaint I made
about Madame Kovarian when I talk about
series seven of the show she takes a
little too much joy in what she does for
me to find her interesting I would be
more interested if I ever got the sense
that she didn't enjoy the horrible
things she did but she did firmly
believe they were what should be
happening or what needed to happen but
there is this sense of oh doctor I'm
going to enjoy sending you on a suicide
mission thing I'm like yeah like there's
no there's no nuance to this character
it's not a bad performance some of the
performances are
including her but there's just there's
there's no depth to her as a character
so I don't enjoy her I don't like that
she is apparently recurring across the
Time Lord Big Finish things apparently a
total ton of them so I don't love that
the other supporting cast is pretty good
there is the effective companions is a
is a native on the planet that the
doctor initially crashes on and then
comes back to later named rejoice and we
get to hear her twice a younger version
an older version both of them very good
both of them with a pretty good
performance dynamic with John Hurt which
I suppose brings me to John Hurt's
performance and it is gonna hurt me a
lot to say this but I don't love it it's
really hard for me to pin down what it
is it's not the acting choices and it's
not the scripting it's just and like I
know he's done radio he knows how to do
radio if I were to guess what was
throwing me off it's just the
combination of sort of the extra vocal
work that inherently comes with doing
audio work you know putting more
emphasis on characterizing your
emotional beats through your voice
combined with how strained his voice was
towards the end of his life and I hate
to pin my issues with a performance on
something that couldn't be helped but I
think it's a contributing factor where a
line delivery that maybe is supposed to
just be at least in my mind is supposed
to be like slightly sad exasperated
comes across with way more force just
because of the amount of effort he had
to put into to get the words out like
you could hear the strain in his voice
I think in overcoming that strain to get
the performance it overcooks it and it
it's not bad I just didn't click with it
and I hate not clicking with a doctor
there are a few things as a Doctor Who
fan that bummed me out more than that
every time I watch or listen to another
story with Peter Davison I keep hoping
maybe this one
maybe it'll finally click and then when
it doesn't it bums me out and I really
thought I was gonna click with the war
doctor on this but I didn't and I think
part of the thing is is that there
doesn't seem to be a ton of again nuance
to these characterization beyond grumpy
and not really wanting to be there which
is fitting like I buy it it's it's not
like no that doesn't make sense no makes
total sense but I feel like we've just
got the base level of what the doctor is
in terms of no morals peppering of
arrogance and all that and then just
little layer grumpy that's good it feels
like it feels like the kind of
characterization that would come out of
an improv exercise do the doctor but
grumpy do the doctor but high on pot the
of that sort of that sort of improv
prompt he feels like do the doctor book
grumpy and if competent it's it's fine
it makes sense but like it's it is
lacking depth this whole set desperately
lacks depth and the thing is I'm
actually becoming weary of episodes
written by Nicholas Briggs I love the
work he's done as one of the overseers
and masterminds behind Big Finish but
whenever I've listened to stories that
he actually scripted they usually don't
do a lot for me and again that's kind of
annoying because broad terms I like the
man's worked and he does great work
voice in the Daleks and the Cybermen but
when I when I listen to the stories
actually scripted by him they usually
top out it was pretty good
his approach just lacks the
inventiveness that makes me love Big
Finish at its best and it's that exact
thing and like across the board from
scenario to to location to plot
progression to the characterization of
the doctor there is a lack of
imagination I'm not gonna call it boring
I'm not even gonna call it bad just
maybe I just build it up too much of my
head maybe that's it I don't know I just
didn't find a lot to love in this boxset
that really bummed me out hopefully when
I get to the Missy boxset that'll go
down better but the War Master series
one only the monstrous which also had to
end on him saying the title of the what
did you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down on the
comments let's talk about a bunch of
stuff to do like subscribe so we're only
on patreon that is a massive massive
help but even if you don't do that share
this around with your friends and you
know I've got links for the stuff
besides merch and I've written them I
wrote a book available there's an amazon
link etcetera etc it said but you also
don't have to do any of it because end
of the day you're the council I just run
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]